I think he's a little slow and what she
used I was slow too man yeah Bart was so
slow
[Music]
all right I'm gonna tell you guys about
a very disturbing story
on it's it's pretty crazy you may have
seen little tidbits of this here and
there but it happened uh the first uh
the first initial incident happened in
2015 okay it's in Texas why are you
smiling if it's bad no that's just his
mustache yeah it just makes it look like
he's smiling yeah it's the default
Pringles it really works against me at
funerals and events such stuff
I'm really sad just curl it down but it
works well at Civil War reenactment
so in 2015 this is in Texas there's a
kid named Rudy farias
um he disappeared from home at 17 years
old wow so his mom Janie Santana she
reports him missing right
she said that Rudy went to walk his
little puppies and that uh he just
disappeared and they found the puppies
they did not find Rudy were they pugs uh
it doesn't say I think if they were pugs
they would have said but uh no they must
not be okay very cute interesting so uh
she she went as far as accusing this
like human trafficker like Mexico that
he was probably the one that did it she
even traveled down to like identify a
body to see if it was Rudy damn it
wasn't and then there was like four
private investigators working on this
thing trying to find the kid he's not
like a kid he's 17 but they they really
it's not a disappearance at the time he
disappeared he was 17. uh they put in
hundreds of hours to look for him and
then she started a GoFundMe uh with a
goal of like 75 000 nothing is turning
up and then eight years later
he was actually found
um
but then it turns out Janie Santana the
mother was actually just hiding him in
the house for eight years oh
oh why what for that 75 grand
what is your motherly instincture
he did a crime
he didn't do crime now oh was he was he
being hidden like against his will or
like he was part of it against his will
so basically during 17 though I know
yeah so during the years that he was
missing like family members had actually
said they saw him at the house or they
would see him around and they tried to
report it to the police that like yo
this kid is not missing he's right there
and then when cops would come over she
would have him act like he's someone
else and like give a fake I'm not Rudy
I'm duty duty yeah they would say Duty
yeah
so uh he would uh what they would say
that he's the nephew and not the son
there's no like records of
identification of this human being for
17 years it just never got that far like
sometimes they would get pulled over and
she would be like say this name say this
date of birth and they would just always
get away with it for eight years and um
I think that [__] liked it too
though yeah
at 17. like what was his so he's a
little bit more of like a shy kid and
kind of like now that some information
is coming out and there's gonna be way
more to come out we're still like
literally at the nothing point but let's
make assumptions now though but uh he
apparently has been mentally manipulated
for like most of his life she's like one
of those really overbearing moms that
kind of controls his every hour yeah and
uh everything he does in his life is
just for her like she would take him to
work and make him do like her job that's
time she'll make him do like 12 hour
shifts I mean that's why you have kids
right you got to make them work like
that's why people had like 10 kids on
their farm so then I guess you get the
Beats you do this you pick the
strawberries and then we call them
chores straight to the Beats you have a
beet farming fish he's been watching
videos now you've been watching videos
we've been watching China Tick Tock
let's do it so the um the crazy thing is
when Rudy was questioned my police like
when he goes in to talk to them there's
a guy who said he was in the room this
guy's name is quanell X
the way it was his name that's the
coolest name ever dude is that his rap
name
I think it's his RnB yeah what's up my
name is
it's a guy named he's described as a
community activist he apparently was in
the room when Rudy was talking to uh
authorities and he said why would he be
in the room I don't know and then he
said that Rudy was insinuating that
um his mom
would make him sleep with her in the bed
and play Daddy
wait why'd you throw up
the [__]
that's what he's insinuating Quan XL
something that he that Rudy said that in
the initial questioning but after like
Queen Alex came out and like did some uh
News interviews saying that the police
were like no that's not true like he
never said that didn't why would they
say that there's no evidence of that but
then um and then even Rudy came out
later and said that no I'm not having
sex with my mom dude but Cornell X has
doubled down after that and said no that
is what he said his mom is telling him
to lie now
but why would Mr Kwan be in there yeah
Mr Quan
it just says Community activism what
does Korean guy doing man what's his
deal dude Malcolm X's nephew yeah and I
thought it was XL Excel
like extra lot like people do like a
Chino XL and something like I never
heard of LX no it's Cornell
it's not like Honda Civic LX yeah that's
what I thought in my head it was initial
yeah his name's Cornell and then he has
like an action type bar I thought it was
quad
that's what I thought nine other
quantums so he messed up with this name
bro yeah what the [__] was he doing in
the room so the weird thing there's a
lot of really strange things around this
super weird yeah one one of them they
mentioned could be weird is that his so
his father's dead for real dad though
for real we're missing for like 12. I've
been hiding and playing sun and the bed
his older brother actually passed away
too from a motorcycle accident and for
some reason he had a life insurance
policy out and the benefit
um what is it called the beneficiary the
beneficiary beneficiary benefit you just
copy your answer
is Rudy
solely just Rudy yeah cause mom's
[__] crazy why are all the men dying
in this household so you think maybe
he's she's trying to control Rudy to get
access to she cut the brakes on the
motorcycle maybe and put the life
insurance on her son but the Daddy's
still out there sleeping with mom
playing son whoa so even though that's
what he said his family's [__] up even
though the mom has like done all these
like donation things to try to get muddy
and everything and you say the mom's
name is Joel Santana Janie Santana I was
like this is [__] up then yeah that's
funny this is [__] up man the crazy
thing is that even though she filed
false reports from the police and did
all this like [__] that you're not
supposed to do the
um the D.A is not pursuing any charges
on her I don't understand is it the D.A
is the daddy
sorry the Daddy's dead I'm sorry yeah we
got to figure out I don't get this daddy
starts with D.A I'm just saying is it a
victimless crime because I don't really
know what why it's a big deal for him
he's like he's 17. he's just home he's
grounded his mom's still cooking food
for him and [__] all right he's 20 he's
26 now right oh no 20 25 yeah well he's
grounded for a long time this just
sounds like an Asian girl's life
but you can't leave the house until
you're married private investigators put
in over 100 hours and go down to Mexico
and look for like a deadbeat you should
make it look real yeah she was like
trying to falsify and then like all
these like family members have come out
saying that she is crazy and that she
manipulates and tries to make money like
in all these like kind of gypsy stuff is
this considered like hostage Inc
it's holding him hostage it's I don't
think it is because in this state 17 is
adult I believe oh oh that's probably
why they're not pursuing that yeah I
think that's what it says I could be
wrong but it did say that 17 is
considered adult in terms of like parent
to child but is it her fault for being a
mother that tells her child to do chores
yeah like sleep with her and call him
daddy if it's true but the guy's denying
it that's Quan lx's take that's
incredible 17 he says honestly if if
he's 17
he's old enough to make his own
decisions because I remember when my dad
started whipping my ass I ran into a
furniture store for help
and how are you you're like 12. I was
like 11 or 12. see I'm smart so if your
attendance if you're getting pulled over
and you're [__] pretending to be Duty
and giving fake birthdays and you're not
and you're not running out for help
that's on you dude yeah that's true I
think he's a little slow and what she
used I was slow too man yeah Bart was so
slow
what she used against him was that uh so
when his initial Disappearance in 2015
he actually did run away from home but
it was just for a day but what she told
them to do longer than that
what she told him was that um if the
police find you that you're really here
they they're gonna arrest you so he had
this like weird fear like he would just
believe everything she said that people
don't know how to Google [__] dude he
doesn't have Google so that's the whole
like reason this happened didn't she say
he was like
um uh Autistic or something like with
the mom yeah like he couldn't like he
was non-verbal all right am I mixing
that up well she did I guess his
relatives did say that he's like kind of
slow and quiet and shy and a little like
reserved I don't know if he's he's just
got his [__] Essence destroyed but
also for the mom to be able to keep him
hidden for like eight years that's a
long time she's probably really good at
doing that maybe there's also a mixture
of bad policing in here okay see that's
the part that a lot of people are zoning
in on is they think that the reason
they're not pursuing charges the reason
it's kind of getting swept is because
they don't want to take the blame for
the whole thing because if value members
are calling to Cops and saying hey he's
there like this is stupid and there
might be something going on and then the
cops are like we got bigger things to
handle bigger fishes to fry oh they go
there and it's like is that your son no
that's my nephew halluti okay I'm doing
the checks out it's not Rudy it's a
looty you know what I mean well maybe
they don't have to look for it right
because he's an adult now
so they're like that's also another
thing yeah they don't they don't try
that hard for that so the only thing
they should be pursuing is her
falsifying all these things to collect
money but all it takes is one drop of
effort like if you have a description of
a person uh 510 whatever like this
complexion and you literally show up to
the house and you see the person that
matches the exact description yeah and
if you just add okay if that's your
nephew which one of your brothers and
sisters is this person's parent and then
she's probably gonna start stumbling and
you go okay why are they not here and
your nephew's here you know like there's
if you just start asking a few more
questions you know how like cops they'll
ask simple questions and people that are
guilty they certainly they have long
answers
okay I'll come back later because I know
this is where it's at you know that's
why they couldn't defeat her because all
she said was that's Duty
and he's like all right
let's go get some Sonic check sucks if
let's say that's let's say that's the
situation right let's say the cops are
trying to downplay the whole thing
because they don't want the the shame
and the trouble of having drop the ball
yeah then it makes sense that they're
trying to say that no molestation
occurred
because that changes the whole dynamic
of the case right yeah if he's like
having to play Daddy and it gets
re-categorized that oh exactly yeah then
it's like a then they really [__] up
also take one Alex to jail yeah shut him
up yeah this guy needs to go to Joe
who's that guy now I know he's
considered an adult but I wonder at what
point would like Social Services be able
to get involved to be able to be like um
not after they're adults you know who's
gonna Crack the Case go fund me they're
gonna be like was that a fraudulent
raising the funds because you got to
give us at least 20 if it is that's what
they're gonna say tick tock makes to get
on this yeah there's a you're gonna
probably see a little bit of this pop up
and so far these are just the confirmed
facts there's a lot more other things
that are kind of in the air but um when
you hear something you're gonna be
pretty you know what I think we need I
think we need a team of Internet sleuths
to figure that I agree yeah we need to
see some collateral lives ruined yes
yeah the ones that don't even live in
Texas yeah live outside of Texas Maybe
across the world maybe and then see if
that helps
[Music]
foreign